Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in my audience.
We do these via discord, which you can find at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's start
today with Yarrow from Brooklyn Yarrow. You're on
the air. I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly.
Speaker 2: Hello, David, it's yarrow, yarrow.
Speaker 1: OK, I apologize.
Speaker 2: No worries, thank you
for answering my calls. Good to be on the show.
My pleasure. The question I actually had was I
live in Brooklyn in the Russian speaking part of
it, and the conversation's been going along, going
around about what's going to happen with Ukraine
and Russia. And I was actually curious about your
personal opinion. What do you think will kind of
happen kind of in all of this? Do you think that
Russia will kind of collapse from sanctions or do
you think it's going to more or less turn into a
win? So I'm kind of curious as to your take on it.
Speaker 1: I think, by the way,
are you like down in Brighton Beach?
Speaker 2: Yes, I am. OK, Brighton
Beach. Beautiful area. In the summer, certainly.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, OK. I mean, listen. I think
at this point, we're all really just guessing,
but I think that regardless of what happens
militarily, Russia's economy is going to be in
very bad shape for at least years to come as a
result of the sanctions. Absolutely. I don't I'm
not leaning in the direction of Russia's going
to take Ukraine. I don't think that that's
the most likely scenario. I think sort of
it's not one or the other thing. So
there's more than one possibility.
But I think the most likely scenario is that
there are some off ramp created for Putin,
where he saves a little bit of face, but not that
much. And Russian troops stay in some regions of
Ukraine, like the Donetsk and Luhansk, and sort
of like things are just not good for anybody
moving forward for many years like that, I
think is unbalanced the most likely outcome?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that is the general fear
among kind of the Russian and Ukrainian
population here as well in Brighton. Yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I now are the Russian
folks you speak to opposed to what Putin is doing.
Speaker 2: For the most part, yes. Yeah.
Speaker 1: That makes sense, that
makes sense, and everything's
still good at Coney Island and everything.
Speaker 2: Oh yeah. I mean, for the most part,
you could kind of tell in Brighton Beach, the
atmosphere has been a little bit depressed in the
last few weeks. Just people are just cheery, even
by Russian standards, right? Ukrainian standards.
But, you know, hopefully it'll pass with time.
Speaker 1: Fair. All right. Very
good. I appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you very much, everybody.
Speaker 1: There we go. Great to
hear from Brooklyn. Always great.